all of this
is way more simple
then what is appearing in the complexity
of what is being communicated
in culture
what's going on with wall street bets is
simply a downstream symptom
of egoic consciousness and
exclusive stakeholding
wall street bets is a push
for inclusive equity it's a push
for skin in the game it's a push for
inclusive stakeholding
it's a push for humans to redesign the
social contract
and to biomimic the way that
mycorrhizal networks work with mycelium
and trees underground in a two-way
resource exchange
we have tokenomics we have smart
contracts we have
the ability to create inclusive equity
in the shared
growing pie for everybody but
egoic levels of consciousness in the
greatest positions of leadership across
the planet
are making it so that people are
self-dealing
just for their own sake and excluding
out the vast majority of the population
from the growing pie it's a
really really simple analysis when you
go all the way upstream
you have to go all the way upstream just
like you go
all the way inward in terms of
recognizing awareness or consciousness
as eternal and as shared
and being the
agent that we use to
experience these creation designs these
dreamed realities
this is just one of those when you go
all the way inward you
make the recognition of eternity of
infinity
and awareness as the agent that is
experiencing these dream creation
designs
the same thing happens when you go all
the way upstream
into our social contract architectures
and our lack of planetary goal
congruence
and ecological disharmony and
also the levels of consciousness
that are egoic that are in the greatest
positions of power
across the planet when you go all the
way upstream
what you find is those errors that are
then creating all of these downstream
symptoms which wall street bets is one
of the downstream
symptoms of that upstream issue
that we face it is that [ __ ] simple
it's not complicated it's so simple
so what do we do we're not going to
band-aid the downstream symptoms anymore
which is what a vast majority of
planetary thinking
and solution space does we have to go
all the way
upstream to enlightened levels of
consciousness go
all the way upstream to the social
contract
architectures to the planetary goal
congruence the ecological harmony
the inclusive equity and stakeholding
for everybody moving forward
that's the only way to optimize
and it requires the recognition from
those enlightened states
that the other is actually the self
is the one witness the one observer the
one awareness but a different
unique expression of that infinite and
all you have to do is look
at the pupil to recognize what we share
and what is eternal and look at the iris
to see the unique coloration of each
expression of infinity that we
are and the seam nicholas celeb has been
talking about this for a long time
as skin in the game it's that simple
it's that there are current asymmetries
that exist
that don't have skin in the game for the
people
that are taking the vast majority of the
fruits but have
absolutely none of the risk and those
asymmetries are creating the vast
majority of the planetary issues along
with the go at consciousness and these
types of things
so what we need to do is we need to
create skin in the game just like there
was three thousand seven hundred years
ago with the code of hamurabi
and the beginnings of civilization where
you had
things like when an architect would
build a house or
a property what would happen is that if
that house or property would collapse on
the
purchaser of that house or property the
architect would be killed
that's what skin in the game means it's
that simple
and there's other examples like in the
world wars where we had people like
my great uncle and a lot of your
family members as well that experience
things like
the engineers and the architects that
would
be responsible for constructing the
bridges that would be used
during these wars for the troops and the
vehicles and the tanks to go across
those architects and engineers would be
put in boats
underneath of those bridges in the river
and they would have to sit there
underneath of the bridge that they
architected
because that's what skin in the game
means because if that bridge collapses
then the architects and engineers die
that's [ __ ] skin in the game and so
right now
you have a bunch of asymmetries in wall
street
where you have absolutely nobody's feet
were held to the fire after 2008
it's so disgusting all of the
asymmetrical risk was put on the
taxpayers
to alleviate the burden that the
wall street bankers were able to take
the vast majority of the fruits and the
benefits from
these are disgusting asymmetries that
literally take a [ __ ] on the vast
majority of people
in order for the soul profiteering of a
very small
fraction of elites
and we only escape from these
cancerous pathological asymmetries
due to incredible innovations like what
satoshi nakamoto published
literally six weeks after lehman
brothers collapsed with the bitcoin
white paper
because what it does is it creates the
futuristic decentralized cryptographic
tokenomic driven protocols that take the
power away from the greedy
tiny fraction of elites and put it back
in the power of
all eight billion people to have an
inclusive share
and stake of equity in the growing pie
of civilization
and this is also something that bernie
sanders has been peddling for the last
couple of decades
when he's literally been saying that
just put a half a percent tax on all
wall street transactions
and put that money into planetary
air water food shelter
education healthcare
electricity energy the basic needs
so you have a growing population of
people
that are siding on the
complete laissez-faire style dynamics
around economics which are extremely
cancerous because that's exactly what
birthed
the sackler family and purdue pharma
that created the egregious opioid
epidemic around the planet
or in 1906 if john muir and teddy
roosevelt didn't get together
and create the american antiquities act
and say that these planet
these national parks on our planet in
the united states are way too
beautiful we have to create the national
park service and we have to create
the democratization of the beautiful
ecological harmony that these provide
for us
so that the next generations for
hundreds of years can enjoy these
without coming in
and just chopping down all of the trees
and mining out all the resources
so you have to understand that a hundred
percent losses fair does not work
you have to do things like put a half a
percent tax on wall street transactions
in order to be able to take the dynamics
of the elite and create
more symmetries in the sense of
providing the inclusive stakeholding
for the basic needs of people around the
united states and around the planet to
be
met it is literally that simple
and you can also do things like look at
what the [ __ ] happened in 1971 something
that eric weinstein has been really
adamant about drilling into our psyche
as well
in the last 50 years you can literally
see a
bifurcation in real gdp increasing while
median male income flat lines
and you wonder what's going on what are
the core
variables that are altered that are
doing things like moving us off of the
gold standard the globalization of the
elite and manufacturing around the
planet
that are causing the last
generation of our parents
and their parents to be able to do
things like on a single
father's income be able to
afford their full house to be paid off
and to send both their kids to college
and to buy
another house in the woods on a lake
and buy a boat for that house while the
mom stays at home
on one father's income
and 50 years later that is absolutely
not possible even for the wealthiest
1 of engineers
and programmers that work at the major
tech companies
even they can't afford to do what we
just described a moment ago
let alone a basic electrician from 50
years ago
compared to the one percent top
programmers alive 50 years later today
you have to look at things on a macro
level geopolitical geoeconomic
inclusive stakeholding level to be able
to see
how to architect at the most upstream
level the proper protocols that create
the downstream harmony
the more enlightened we become the more
we recognize how to architect the social
contract the more
easy and frictionless and harmonic our
downstream will be
everybody should be fractional owners
and not spectators
we should make inclusive equity now pie
growth for everybody using tokenomics
using smart contracts and leveraging
biomimicry
like we said in high-level perception
our first book in chapter 5 on inclusive
stakeholding
mycorrhizal networks which 95 of trees
use underground in order to have a
two-way
resource exchange via mycelium so that
the mycelium
will take out nitrogen phosphorus
potassium water and distributed to trees
meanwhile trees will sequester carbon
and undergo photosynthesis and
distribute the sugar to the mycelium
guys that's the same exact thing like a
mother tree one of the hub trees
is just like a high net worth person on
the planet it's not like the mother tree
takes the additional sugar that's
created from photosynthesis
and then [ __ ] holds on to it and
hoards it no it distributes it we have
to
create the protocols and architectures
that make it so that these high net
worth people around the planet can
trustingly distribute these additional
sugar
slash money in this case it's all energy
at the end of the day
to the nodes aka the humans
that still need more of their basic
needs to be met so that they can undergo
the process of god realization the
enlightenment as well as the god
actualization of their unique gifts
into the world which then ends up anyway
enlightening the entire planet and
architecting more harmonious and
prosperous protocols that then affect
positively those mother trees aka those
high net worth
individuals and families
and we have the modern day decentralized
tokenomics
mechanism design smart contracts that
are available to us to create this
inclusive equity and inclusive
stakeholding
again it's consciousness and social
contract architectures that are more
the most upstream problem we don't know
ourselves as the same one
infinite creator therefore we don't have
goal congruence as a civilization
when i don't know that you
are the same expression of the one
infinite creator
that i am in this dreamed creation
design
your iris is the uniqueness about you
and the iris is the uniqueness about me
but the pupil is what is shared about
our infinitude about our eternity
about our godness
about our absoluteness about the
ultimate
then we're going to create all of these
ridiculous malevolences that occur
because we don't know that about
ourselves
we have to see the self in the other
in order for us to understand our shared
eternal being
in this just being one expression of a
dreamed creation design
that we are playing in
as lila as the divine play as the
beautiful symphonic song that is being
expressed
and in order to play more in tune in the
song
you have to be willing to architect
the basic needs and protocols for
maximizing prosperity for everybody
when you're egoic when you're a separate
finite contracted energy
entity you're greedy you're
self-dealing everything you're
prioritizing yachts and private jets and
sports cars and designer brands instead
of the basic air
water food shelter ecology electricity
education and healthcare
around the planet and that's the most
upstream issue
when you don't know thyself as was
literally written
2 500 years ago on the top of the temple
of apollo at delphi
know thyself means know yourself
as infinite as eternal as that one
infinite creator
as god as an expression of that and know
the
other as that as well because when you
know the
others all eight billion as the one
infinite creator expressing itself
in these dreamed realities then you
[ __ ] get it
then you get that the absolute best you
can do is to god realize
and then architect out the most
beautiful planetary protocols around
prosperity abundance and well-being
otherwise it's a disaster and it leads
to things like the parable of the rich
fool from luke 12 13
which is an incredible biblical story
where
just like today in modernity you have a
bunch of rich people that are storing
their abundant harvests
and they're not sharing they're not rich
towards god
they're trying to architect all of these
barns and these storage facilities for
their harvest
aka the swiss banks aka this ultra high
net worth madness that's happening
where the abundance from the harvest is
being stored there with all of these
security
measures and all of these guards and all
of these
all of that insanity rather than in all
of these
perennial spiritual traditions what is
said is
take the excess harvest take
that abundance and store it in
the stomach of your fellow brothers and
sisters
actualize their fullest potential via
their basic needs
the planetary rich should be the first
people
that have their consciousness targeted
towards enlightenment and away from
egoic levels
so that they can recognize to not fall
into the parable of the rich fool
but rather to maximize planetary
prosperity and abundance
and again it's simply recognizing the
other as
the self looking at the pupil which is
the same shared
eternal observer and the iris is the
unique expression in this dream
creation design and again the parable of
the rich fool has a lot to do with the
delphic maxim
nothing in excess whereas
the hedge funds that are combated by
wall street bets
are basically everything in excess
you i'll take the
fifth yacht in the third private jet in
the 17th house in the 50th car
and the 40th designer watch and the
100th designer
clothing item because they see
themselves
as separate when you have an egoic level
of consciousness you see yourself as a
complete
separate independent finite contracted
energetic entity
and you don't see the others as
the same one infinite creator expressing
itself
and that's where all of these [ __ ]
issues
come from
so only those that understand our
metaphysical truth can be trusted with
the world
egoic consciousness getting zapped like
a moth
that flies into the white source light
just like in the parable of the prodigal
son in the bible that
you go outward first and then you
recognize
that i just hit an egoic breaking point
i can't seek happiness and peace
externally so i turn inward and i
recognize that
awareness is it consciousness is
it that is what is shared that is what
is eternal that is god that is infinity
expressing itself through us we share
that and once you get that then you get
metaphysical truth then you can be
trusted with being an
architect of the planet
and that's why the ego gets zapped like
a moth that goes to that white source
light and then there's
in a sense it's like wu way it's the
effortless
butterfly effect action going outward as
lauza said
it's a rebirth of non-dual infinite
awareness going outward to architect the
protocols that maximize human potential
where stewardship is number one and
again it's simply
fixing the most upstream root issues
or meme stocks and more will continue
to birth to course correct us
that is ultimately what wall street bets
that is
ultimately what anything that arises in
these downstream scenarios
is just trying to course correct four
egoic levels of consciousness is trying
to course correct for
exclusive stakeholding and is trying to
course correct us towards enlightenment
it's trying to correct us
towards architecting inclusive
stakeholding and inclusive equity that
biomimics
the intelligence of mycorrhizal networks
that are a billion years old
here you have humans that are decades of
years old
that think of themselves in these hedge
funds
and in these high net worth scenarios as
completely egoic
separate finite entities that are not
looking at the one billion year old
mycorrhizal network's
harmony and intelligence there and
because of that not being exposed to
that information
and never undergoing a process of
turning inward to recognize
the shared eternal observer that we all
are are going outward and thinking of
themselves
as separate egoic
finite and then self-dealing being
greedy
and that's where you have all of these
downstream issues that have arised it is
that
simple it's nowhere near as difficult as
we are making it out to be
go all the way upstream when you go all
the way
upstream you recognize our metaphysical
truth you go inward you become aware of
awareness
aware of consciousness aware of how it's
shared and how it is eternal
and how this is but one expression of
that one dreamed creation design
and how we share our being which is what
love means love is the recognition that
we share our being
and you just look at the pupil and
that's what's shared and you look at the
iris and that's what's unique
and then also when you go inward all the
way you recognize that
what's most upstream also is the actual
social
contract architectures those have to
have a high level of goal congruence
leveraging especially modern tokenomics
and smart contracts
to create an inclusive equity inclusive
stakeholding that biomimics things like
mycorrhizal networks
so that everybody has a share in the
growing prosperous pie
that's it
just go and look at naseem teleps skin
in the game
go and look at the code of hammurabi
go and understand how the modern day
decentralization and cryptographic and
tokenomic protocols
can be leveraged to create inclusive
stakeholding and inclusive equity with
everybody moving forward
and especially those in the positions of
greatest power around the planet
we must pressure the living [ __ ] out of
them to become enlightened faster
and to move away from egoic levels of
consciousness for that moth to go inward
and get zapped by the white source light
so that it becomes a non-dual infinite
awareness going outward
in its expression that is harmonious and
prosperous
with maximizing human potential
that's all
if the video brought you value like the
video please
if you haven't yet subscribe to the
channel also comment below with your
thoughts
share the video with other people that
you feel this would bring value to
and if you'd like to you can join us on
the channel here and gain exclusive
benefits and perks which we funnel all
of that
revenue directly back into actualizing
all of our
projects
that's all most upstream enlightenment
consciousness and inclusive equity and
stakeholding
adore you thank you
you